yep that's angelina jolie
the beekeeper they're you know they're
my friends
on wednesday angelina donned a full
beekeeping uniform to celebrate
graduates of her women for bees
program and i hope that even women
around the world that work on projects
like this reach out to us
join us and we all we all connect in
this network
and all the male beekeepers the program
was held at the french observatory of
operology
you could plant a few flowers you could
you should spread a bit of awareness
i don't think we can continue on the
path where
we are on or we've been on to create the
30-day training course
angelina partnered with unesco and the
french cosmetics brand
gurlon it's just changing your mindset
and it's appreciating the pollinators
and it's understanding how your food's
connected so this is an investment
in you know in in all that needs to be
done
the initiative is one of angelina's many
activist projects
and this one holds a special importance
for the oscar winner
due to its focus on women i love to see
women
reach their full potential but also i
know that a woman who is educated
educates others and so the reason why
this sisterhood
is so important is because i know that
the women who receive their diplomas
today
will be sharing that knowledge will be
raising up
others around the world during her
address
angelina discussed everyday things
people can do to help the bee population
the nice thing about it is it's
something you can anyone can do you
don't have to have a large amount of
land you could have a
you know you could keep a few bees you
could plant a few flowers
you could you should spread a bit of
awareness the ceremony
comes shortly after this up close and
personal photo shoot for the star
in may angelina helped national
geographic celebrate world bee's day
only this time she didn't have those
protective layers
i'm not still sure what we can say and
later this year angelina will be trading
in the beekeeping uniform
for a superhero suit when she makes her
mcu debut
in the long-awaited marvel movie
eternals we have watched
unguided we have helped them
progress
[Music]
and seen them accomplish
wonders playing a superhero puffs you up
a little bit makes you feel a little bit
more empowered
it does but it's a little you know what
it is though you get the outfit on and
you're feeling really like you know and
then you see your kids and you're like
you know and then the way they look at
you like what are you doing
you know then you get nicely brought
back down to earth like you are so weird
[Music]
mom